name something you're obsessed with
right now
um
i'm obsessed with blake shelton blake
shelton and gwen stefani are coming up
on one year of marriage
sometimes i just feel like i'm in a
dream and the no doubt singer is a true
example of wedded bliss
i think somebody that can make you laugh
constantly is very sexy and somebody
that is humble
kind down to earth
selfless
talented on the top of their game should
i keep going
the 52 year old former voice coach
stopped by ellen on wednesday and opened
up about their first year as husband and
wife he's my best friend we have so much
fun and sure they're both famous
musicians who live glamorous rock star
lives but guys their current passion
gardening yeah gardening on blake's
ranch in oklahoma we're talking about
daffodils we're talking about like
tulips every we already did the olive
bulbs now we're doing we did wildflower
seeds now we're doing zinnias it's
so you're doing something we want them
home to figure out how to till all the
land and dig a well so it's gonna be
good he's working on the well digging
today and i'm not kidding pretty cute
right it's one of those once in a
lifetime
you know moments well it gets even cuter
i think about all the different seeds
that were planted in my life the seeds
of faith like the seeds of just these
ideas and these wild ideas i had that
actually came true
and even the one to like fall in love
with blake and it's crazy because now
i'm gonna go back there and plant so
many flowers and they're to bloom and
it's so exciting but
there's just so much like relevance
between the two things like if you think
about it back in november gwen dished to
e.t about going back to oklahoma for the
holidays for the first time since their
july nuptials we have not been back
there since the wedding so i'm really
looking forward to it and we have a new
house there we have like a new life
there so it's gonna be it's gonna be our
first married thanksgiving very grateful
very excited the couple said i do last
july in front of their closest friends
and family with their good pal carson
daly officiating it was like the perfect
amount of people it was so intimate it
was so exactly what it needed to be and
yeah it was just and not just the
wedding but the marriage is so fun and
i'm so into it so i feel very blessed i
love seeing like the smile on your face
you just seem like you're in the best
phase of your life would you say that's
true i'm in the best phase of my life
you feel more grateful than ever i mean
truly we do
and during a game of burning questions
gwen revealed the sweet nicknames she
and the 45 year old country singer have
for each other
flaky and pretty girl
i didn't make that up he made it he
calls you pretty girl
hey pretty girl yes he calls me pretty
girl so if your teeth still aren't
aching from all the sweetness let me
just send you off with a proper montage
of all the times they gushed over each
other to et's i think i'm his biggest
fan i learned a lot from from gwen it's
incredible to have
a best friend like that guy
[Music]
you